[Music]  my love for the water really being runs  deep my name is Jenny Adler and I'm a  conservation photographer educator in  National Geographic and Explorer  becoming an underwater photographer  isn't something that I ever considered  growing up all of my dreams about the  future we're always studying the ocean  the two women who are most influential  for me were my mother and grandmother my  grandmother study biology and my mother  taught me to sail  hi girls welcome to Springs if I could  say one thing to young girls I would say  you can be anything it's important to  empower girls because it's crucial for  them to know that their actions matter  and what they do can make a difference  and I wish that more of them could jump  in and experience it in a way that might  change their life you guys did great